- 15 years ago, if you
thought it was a good idea
to pay strange men to drive around
your fourteen-year-old daughter,
you would be laughed out of a room.
Now, parents are more
comfortable with their daughters
going into uber than driving themselves.
We are going through major
major consumer shifts.
(bright upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
(audience cheering)
Don't you wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(bright upbeat music)
Good morning, I'm really
excited to be here
for many different reasons.
One, we have a good amount
of time for this keynote
so I'm gonna be able
to create some context.
Two, I've had the great pleasure,
I run a 1000 person marketing agency
and Chase Bank has been a
great client for a long time
and I've been very close to that account.
And even before that, had
worked with a bunch of people
in the credit union industry
on their marketing strategies,
so I always enjoy when
I have much more context
of the day to day.
So that's a lot of fun.
And three, I had an incredible breakfast
with a small group of people
that are in the audience
and just the quality of the questions
and the vibe in general excite me.
So, thank you for having me this morning,
thanks for being up.
I got in late last night from New York
and noticed a bunch of you
were still running around
a little bit later.
And so the fact that you're
here this morning is impressive.
Many different places where I wanna go,
one, I'm gonna give you a little
context of how it got here
because I'm gonna assume a
lot of you don't know who I am
but number two, I think a
great way to start this talk
is very simply this.
You're about to find out that I grew up
in the liquor business and launched one
of the first e-commerce wine businesses.
So I grew up in an
unbelievably regulated business
my entire career.
I've had the great privilege of working
in the financial sector for
some of the biggest clients
in the world over the last half decade.
And the thing that
keeps ringing in my mind
as I was getting up this morning is,
I think in 2019, as we
head into the next decade,
I think this needs to be the conference,
this needs to be the moment,
this needs to be the time
that this collective room
starts really putting
their mind in this place
where they realize that
using regulation as an excuse
to not innovate is not
a sustainable strategy.
I think the reality is that
so many people in this sector
default into blaming
regulation as an excuse
to not learn the new communication portals
that matter to our end consumer.
I stand here today, and
the reason I started
a marketing company a decade
ago was because marketing
for me a decade ago after
investing in Facebook and Twitter
and Tumblr, after being
an early investor in Uber
and being a big better on
Netflix when it went public,
I genuinely believed that
there are so many innovations
upon us whether it's blockchain,
whether it's peer-to-peer,
whether it's online competitors.
There's so much innovation
from a business standpoint.
It's so difficult for so many
people here to go back home
and really rejigger their app
or their website to be
lacking the friction
needed to compete in a 2020 world,
this is like practical
in the trenches stuff.
But the one place that is very
practical to begin the battle
that is needed for the
companies and organizations here
to compete in the next
year let alone next decade,
the one place you can adjust quickly
is your marketing strategy
and marketing spend.
It is hard to go back and rebuild
a tech stack infrastructure,
it is much easier
to go back and cut your
direct mail budget in half
then allocate it somewhere else.
This is a very important
time in this industry,
it's a very important time in our society.
There's a real massive
naivete in the collective
of understanding that the
Internet is the middleman
and that everybody else is just waiting
for their time to be exposed.
Books got picked on first
but then along the way,
I was saying this morning, just
only six or seven years ago
I was in D.C. giving a
keynote to the black car
and taxi industry desperately
trying to get them
to understand that uber was a problem.
And what everybody did in that conference
is what everybody does in every industry
which is they come up with
the excuses or concepts
that they hope the customer wants
instead of the reality
of the customers needs.
The reality is if you're in this industry
and you create any friction
towards a transaction
for an end consumer,
they're not interested.
We value time.
So again back to my investing career,
I invested nine years ago in Venmo, right.
When I think about the
dynamics that that played out,
and that one didn't work out as well
'cause it didn't operate to its success,
it's sold early and in branch
tree really made the dollars
but the thesis was right.
And the reason so many of the things
that have happened in my
career have worked out
is because I'm blindly consumer centric.
Anytime you think about
what's in it for you
versus what's in it for the user of you,
you're already vulnerable.
And I do believe that we are
upon a very important decade
of technology innovation
that only building
your actual brand will be
able to compete against.
We are only a decade away from at scale.
So many of our customers
making financial decisions
through the Alexa or Google
home or apple pod in their home,
and when you understand what
that toll booth looks like,
it's gonna make Google
search of the last decade
seem like child's play.
So let me take a step back
and give you a framework
because I actually think
five minutes of context
of how I got here will help you understand
what I'm about to push that
I think you have to consider.
I was born in the former Soviet Union,
I came here when I was three years old.
It was a super hardcore lifestyle,
I mean I lived in a studio apartment,
half the size of the stage
that I'm standing on right now
with seven family members.
My dad got a job as a
stock boy in a liquor store
and used to drive from
Queens to New Jersey
for two bucks of an hour
which just tells you
how cheap gas used to
be, and it was really,
it was a hardcore struggle.
I went on one family vacation
in my whole childhood
we finally moved to Ades in
New Jersey about five or six,
four or five years in, six,
five years into America
because my dad became the
manager of a liquor store
in a town next door.
That is where my
entrepreneurial career began.
I started a lemonade stand and then,
I should be honest here,
I manipulated my friends
to stand behind the other five
lemonade stands I created.
So I had a six lemonade stand franchise
(audience laughing)
and for everybody here over the age of 38,
you might remember big
wheels, those little things
that we used to ride as kids.
I used to ride my big wheels
to every one of my locations
at the end of the day to collect my cash
like I was Tony Soprano or something.
(audience laughing)
So that's who you have on stage.
Actually, now I'm gonna go...
I appreciate the laughs,
so I'm actually gonna
really bring it to you.
Actually, six months before that business,
my first actual business was
going into people's yards,
ripping their flowers out of their yard,
ringing their doorbell and
selling it back to them.
So not the proudest year of my life.
But I was super entrepreneurial, I'm 43,
so I had the benefit of being of the age
when baseball cards and
sports cards got really big
and was a huge phenomenon.
And when I was 12 years
old, at that point,
I'd already realized that
I was an entrepreneur
even though every other immigrant
was getting straight A's,
I was getting D's and F's.
My mom is just amazing and
built an enormous self-esteem
but she was super frustrated by that part,
so she really said that, if
you're not gonna be a student,
you're gonna have to learn how to work.
So I worked a lot.
But you know for me, this was not
the golden era of entrepreneurship.
Again, depending on what age you are,
you know that the 80s and
90s was the college you go to
is a direct attribution to how
successful or good you are.
So I was making $2,000 to $3,000 a weekend
at these malls in New
Jersey yet all my parents
my parents' friends,
all my friends' parents
and definitely all my teachers told me
I was gonna be a loser.
I don't know about you guys
but when you have $37,000
in cash under your bed
when you're 12 years old
and you're not selling weed,
you're not gonna be a loser.
(audience laughing)
That one's for all the parents
with D and F students out there.
Don't worry guys, it
can work out, it's cool.
Anyway, and you know it's
funny, the way I look at school
in the modern education system and the way
that college is structured
and the debt you have to incur
to get a piece of paper
that no longer translates
to an actual job that
makes it ROI positive
is a lot of the way I think about
being a traditional
financial service provider
in today's environment
when you're not leaning in
to the infrastructure
of the web let alone,
and all of you know this
like, the amount of VC funding
and private equity money
being put into FinTech
and competitors and layers
above and like Cloud...
We're not even talking,
forget about Bitcoin
or cryptocurrency, we're not even talking
about the manifestation
of a mature blockchain.
There's so much pressure on
us collectively in the macro,
what I'm affected by is
the next part of my story.
When I turned 14, my parents said,
okay, the baseball card thing is a fad,
which they were right about,
you need to start working
in the family business.
So I went from making $3,000 a weekend
to making $2 to $3 an hour bagging ice
in the basement of my dad's liquor store.
So I call those the Dark Ages, I hated it.
My dad ran his liquor store
like the Soviet Union,
so his employees didn't
necessarily love him.
So the 14 year old son that look nine
really took the brunt of that.
So it was a tough era but
eventually when I turned 16,
I was allowed upstairs
'cause I was relegated
to the basement and bagging ice
and something amazing happened.
I realized that people collected wine.
Even though my dad's store was called
Shoppers Discount Liquors,
we were in an affluent part
of New Jersey, Short Hills,
Millburn, Summit, Livingston.
Some dollars in the neighborhood
and they would come to the store
and they would ask for
these expensive wines.
Me being bored, started reading about wine
and that connection 'cause I wanted
to help my family business made me realize
there was something there, a passion.
And so by the time I
was 18, no 18 year old
should know as much about wine as I did.
I was off-the-charts wine book smart.
And then I went to school,
freshman year, September 1994,
I'm in my dorm room playing Madden 94,
dominating by the way,
(audience laughing)
and my friend runs in and he says,
you have to come and see this.
At this point, I had already
been really helping my dad,
I had a lot of knowledge, I was
a good salesman on the floor
and I was gonna open up 800
Shoppers Discount Liquors.
I was gonna build the Toys
R Us of liquor stores.
It's kind of how I thought
about it as a 17, 18 year old.
Now I'm in a dorm room in September of 94
and I get pulled out of
my room and I go look
and I see and hear for the first time.
For the under 25 under 30 set here,
you missed one of the great
rackets in business history.
America Online used to
charge three bucks a minute
to be on the internet,
though they gave you a CD
that gave you eight trillion free hours.
It was the first time I saw it,
I said something ridiculously stupid like,
is this the information superhighway
or whatever we called it back then?
I had heard of it, but at
this point I'm 18 years old
just to put into context,
and I'm sure this resonates
with a lot of people in this room,
I'd been on a computer
for 20 hours in my life
'cause of classes, it was just not a part
of my lexicon or my life.
But what happened next
was super interesting.
Within an hour of being on the internet,
but the first time in my life,
I found myself on a bulletin
board selling sports cards
and I realized that this was going to be
what I was going to do.
And so on intuition and just tasting it,
I launched one of the first
three e-commerce wine businesses
in America, 1996, when I
launched winelibrary.com
and rebranded my family's business.
This is where it gets important here.
My objective here today is to not worry
about the macro issues potentially
over the next two decades
because for a lot of
executives and operators here
you won't be around to
see that play out anyway
and that's not practical,
and I have no interest
in ideology or futurism,
I care about general practicality.
I believe the biggest ROI
that I can bring here today
is help people under
and alternatives of what
they could be spending their money on
to communicate to end consumers
to do business with them.
That is what I'm passionate
about on everyday basis.
I have no emotion, you'll hear me talk
about LinkedIn and Facebook and Twitter
and YouTube and a bunch
of things in a little bit,
I have no emotion to them.
I could care less if they spoke in Twitter
and YouTube are around tomorrow or not,
the only thing I do, and it's not up here,
but when you saw my slides earlier,
it says I day trade attention.
The only thing I care
about on an everyday basis
is where is the consumers attention,
how much does it cost to get to them
and how and what creative do
I need to put in front of them
so I can get their business?
But I'm not emotional about it.
I built my family business this way.
I took a business that was
doing $3.8 million in revenue,
10% gross profit, so you can imagine
how little money was left for marketing.
I took a business that, in
1998 when I left school,
and started operating my dad's business
on the back of winelibrary.com
on the back of email marketing
and then on the back of Google AdWords
which were the two big
innovations having a website,
doing email marketing.
How many people here were
doing email marketing
in the late 90s, early 2000s?
Raise your hands.
So for the OGs that
just raised their hands,
(audience laughing)
do you remember those open rates?
I mean I had an email newsletter...
How many people have done email
marketing in their career?
Raise your hands high.
Wait to hear this.
In 1998, I had a 200,000 person newsletter
that had 91% open rates.
(audience laughing)
What I know more than the
sun will come up tomorrow
is I know that marketers ruin everything.
(audience laughing)
As a marketer, I ruined email.
I remember my email newsletter
when I first innovated,
I'm like, maybe I can email people.
And so I emailed like 80 people
and we sold way more wine.
And then I was like, wait a minute,
that didn't cost me anything.
Like the catalog that I used
to send out the same to sell,
the same stuff cost me a fortune.
I remember from 1998 to
2000, sending so much email
'cause I was convinced that eventually
we would charge for it.
Like it was so remarkable.
And I went from emailing once a week
to three times a week to five days a week.
And then two years later, I
was like people read email
on Saturday and Sunday,
so we went to seven.
And then I was like, maybe you can send
more than one email a day.
(audience laughing)
Systematically, from 1998 to 2007,
I destroyed our email newsletter.
(audience laughing)
But on the back of that
and on the back of buying
all the wine terms on Google
AdWords a day it came out,
how many people here have
done Google ad marketing
in their lives?
So the day came out, it
was five cents a click
for about 4/1/2 months before
10 cents became the base.
I literally owned every word,
from wine to Cabernet, to Merlot.
This is where the story of
my career is devastating.
I'm very proud that I built
my family liquor business
from a 3.8 to a 60 million
dollar business in seven years
with no capital, with no VC money.
As a matter of fact, and you'll love this,
this crowd will love this,
my dad's so old-school,
I didn't even know that
credit lines existed.
So I built a business
from three to 60 million
on making every penny work its ass off.
That was email and Google AdWords.
That's what I'm gonna
talk to you about today.
How do you make every
penny work it's ass off?
How do you not, and I think everybody
will resonate with this following line,
the greatest thing that's
happening in marketing right now
is that we put the past on a pedestal
and we demonize the current.
We put the past on a
pedestal, tried and true.
We create bullshit reporting
to justify the spend
and then we ask stuff that has real data
to prove that it works.
That is ludicrous and
that is why we're seeing
so many companies lose
market share and decline.
It's because the executives
behind that feel comfortable
with what got them there
instead of understanding
that's exactly what's
gonna make them vulnerable
and that you should be
required to continue
to up your game and learn new skills
and understand how new things...
People are like, Gary
but I don't understand
how Facebook works!
I'm like, figure it out, dick.
(audience laughing)
Like, isn't that business,
like isn't that the merit
of what we're doing here?
Like the reality is,
that's what's happening.
So I built up that business
on the back of those two
platforms, that was my life,
that's kind of how I did it.
And then a very transcending
moment happened to my career,
and then we'll go into tactics.
YouTube came out, I'd already
built this huge business
and I saw it and I'm
like, this is interesting.
It was about four or five months old
and I started a wine show
called Wine Library TV.
I sat in front of a camera,
drank four bottles of wine for 20 minutes
(audience laughing)
gave my opinions about it
and hundreds of thousands of people
decided to start watching it.
A couple funny things about it,
and this is the number one thing,
and we just had this at the
table, right before I came here,
the reason most people struggle
with contemporary digital marketing
is because they're in sales mode
not providing value and
building brand mode.
You're transactional.
It's like, what did this
post get me, its CAC and LTV,
it's math, it has no brand
or LTV dynamics in it.
I was that person.
Remember the reason I told you is think
about where my DNA
started, rip the flowers,
sell it, right, not good.
Well, great business models,
sat on inventory for no time, high margin
(audience laughing)
but not good morals.
What I thought on February 21st 2006
which is when I first taped
the episode of Wine Library TV,
what I thought I was gonna
do was do QVC, right.
How many people here grew up
in the New York tri-state area
back in the day?
How many of you remember Crazy Eddie?
I thought I was gonna do
Crazy Eddie Meets QVC.
I was gonna be ridiculous in myself
and I was gonna sell wine.
The camera goes on, this
is literally five seconds,
said if you literally go to YouTube
and type in Wine Library TV episode one,
I can see it, I know myself, I don't know
if you'd pick up on it
but somewhere around
one minute into the video,
I'm like, wait a minute,
this is being recorded and
will be on the internet
and will be around forever.
I can't sell, I have to
actually give my actual opinion
on these wines.
And so the reason I became
an internet phenomenon
and why it exploded was
I was literally going
on the internet every
day, five days a week,
to hundreds of thousands of customers
and potential customers
and panning the wines
that I was selling in
my own store at times.
I was being an editorial voice,
not a transactional voice.
What that seed created for me is something
I wanna talk to you about,
but what's really
interesting to this story
and how we got here today is YouTube
sells to Google for $1.7 billion..
I read an article, I'm super
blown away by that number.
I don't know if you guys remember
when that transaction
happened, that was 07,
like it was a very
different world back then.
1.7 billion feels like a trillion today.
It just seemed ludicrous, 90% of the world
had never even heard of
YouTube, it was this big thing.
And in the article it said,
Angel investor Ron Conway
makes X amount of money
on his $25,000 investment,
like 25 million dollars,
something ludicrous.
And I remember thinking,
man, I've been so right
about email and Google
AdWords and now YouTube,
I need to become an Angel investor.
And in 2007 and 2008,
I started doing that.
And the first three
companies I invested in
were Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr.
So I'm rich
(audience laughing)
but more importantly than
that is what happened next
was instead of becoming
a VC, I mean you guys
know this dynamic on the
back of that and uber,
like I wasn't rolling.
And instead of raising two
or $300 million dollars
on a fund, getting two
points, making all that money
just to take meetings and
having 20% of the upside
which is what most of my
friends did from that era,
I decided to build a
20-20 version of Mad Men,
client services, shitty
business, terrible yada,
makes no sense to all my smart friends.
But the reason I did it is
why I find myself here today.
I believe there is a gross underestimation
on how substantial the
consumer behavior shifts are
and are about to be.
If you think a lot of things have changed
over the last five to
seven years, and they have,
in the way we behave, in the way...
I mean dating 15 years
ago, if you online dated
you were the weirdest nerd
in your mom's basement.
Now it is like standard to
swipe left and right 24/7, 365.
Our behaviors in our
society, 15 years ago,
if you thought it was a
good idea to pay strange men
to drive around your
fourteen-year-old daughter,
you would be laughed out of a room.
Now parents are more
comfortable with their daughters
going into uber than driving themselves.
We're going through major
major consumer shifts.
And all the things that
were tried and true
are being pressured by technology.
This industry is on the precipice
of being disrupted dramatically.
Forget about macro technology trends,
just on competitors that
look like Amazon and others.
It's all coming because
the services continue
to be commoditized as
the technology advances.
If you play out the chess moves of that,
it's the same thing that's
happened in politics,
happening in transportation,
it's the same thing that's
happening to book stores,
the wine industry.
What everybody in this room
eventually will realize
and I'd be very grateful
to get an email in 35 years
and be like huh, I
didn't really believe you
but now in hindsight, I'm
surprised how it played out,
you were on it.
I believe one man's point of view,
that if you play out the chess moves
of the advancement of
the inn and technology,
the only thing we are
all left with is brand.
The only thing we were
And why I decided to build
a client service business
and learn marketing was
I was an entrepreneur
in Silicon Valley winner
but I knew nothing
about fortune 5,000 land.
I didn't understand why
the money was being spent
the way it was being spent.
And I needed to go get my
hands dirty and taste it.
And over the last decade, and ironically,
today's the 10-year
anniversary of the business
my brother AJ and I
started called VaynerMedia,
I've learned a ton of stuff most of it
is disappointing to be honest,
most of the reason money is
spent is political and defense
and trying to rise up the ranks.
I used to be mad at you, the individuals,
now are mad at the system, right,
the machine makes people do that.
I'm so tired of CEOs and
board members coming up to me
and saying, Gary, I so believe
in your progressive marketing.
I'm like it's practical,
it's not progressive.
They're like, your progressive marketing
but I can't get my executives
to execute, It's my people...
I go, no it's you.
Employees are easy.
I don't know guys if you've seen this
but it works tremendously
well if you're in control.
You just change what
people get bonus done.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, thanks mom.
Like literally I had dinner
with like a fortune 500 CEO
the other day and she's
amazing and she's like,
I'm just so frustrated,
like I can't get my people!
I'm like, good news.
Instead of your bullcrap internal MMM
or Nielsen brand stuff
lyft or sentiment analysis,
all these stuff, like, there's nothing
that anybody in this room
is held accountable to
from a reporting that
they don't understand
that it's deeply flawed
and easily manipulatable.
You all know this, right.
I mean how many more
meetings do you wanna be in
where the reports like
are sentiments tremendous
but our business sucks crap.
(audience laughing)
And so I said to her, I said look.
if you so believed in
LinkedIn and Facebook,
just change the bonus structure,
just change the rules.
Like I have a funny big idea,
I guarantee that your CMO
and your brand managers are
gonna spend a lot more money
on Facebook if you put a bonus in place
that it you hit this much
Facebook spend, you get bonus.
So like we have enormous
control to change the game
yet people are undereducated.
Do you know many people
are here this morning
that have massive points of
view on Facebook marketing
but have never spent a dollar on Facebook
and seen the results of it?
We live in a world of headline reading.
There are people here of strong
points of view of Facebook,
Google, YouTube,
LinkedIn, all these things
predicated on headlines.
You know many people run
up to me, they're like,
Gary what about Cambridge analytical?
I'm like, what about it Ron?
Ron has no answers.
Target and IRS and visa
breaches put out tons of data.
What we have is a huge
misunderstanding of what consumers
are actually doing.
I'm watching the Venmo's
and the Robin Hood's
and the rocket mortgages and
the blah blah blah blah blah,
draft this and (mumbles),
like brands that are built out of nowhere.
I know kids that are
building 87 different URLs
for nine bucks an hour,
like credit, house income,
home.org running Facebook and Google Ads
and taking customers and making
margin on being referred.
Like the consumers attention
is very clear, it's this.
You may not like that it's this.
You as a human Karen and
Rick, you might not like
that at dinner your kids
on the iPad the whole time.
Two things of that, take the
iPad away and stop complaining,
two, it's the consumer,
you don't get to pick.
Watching people make executive decisions
on how they wish the world was
versus what the actual customer is doing
is one of the most fascinating
things to me of all time.
Like I literally had a meeting
three or four years ago
where the guy was like Gary,
I hear you on this Instagram thing
but I gotta be honest with
you, I just don't get it.
And I go, that's cool John
but you're a 68 year old old white dude
and currently the people that
use it are 16 to 24 year olds.
I don't know if you remember
during this breakfast
but you're the CEO of a company that sells
to 16 to 24 year old women.
This dynamic is amazing,
the amount of companies
in this room that have not taken the leap
into contemporary marketing is fascinating
and it is completely
predicated on one to do things
in this room, it's very simple.
It's just the truth for the
majority, not everybody,
it's either A, the internal machine
doesn't score it positively
and that head of marketing CMO or VP
or whatever it may be doesn't
want to fight the system
and conforms even though she
or he doesn't believe in print
or radio or outdoor or
whatever else commercials,
they do it because that's
what the Machine accepts
and there's no reason after
15 years of great work
for them to make themselves
vulnerable to fight that fight
and so they just conform or
be if they have the autonomy,
they're not comfortable
in these new environments
because they haven't been
practitioners of it themselves
and they're not sure or see
they've run some Facebook
or Google or YouTube ads
and it wasn't successful
and on a small test they decided
the whole thing doesn't work.
The ROI of anything is predicated based on
how good you are at it.
How many people here are familiar
with Wish, the shopping app?
Raise your hands high.
How many people have never heard of it?
Raise your hands high
which I'm gonna assume...
Do me a favor, let's like make a rule
'cause we're about to do some Q and A
two rules this morning;
No half-ass hands.
(audience laughing)
And two, there's no judgment here,
it's just data for each of us,
like there's no reason to hear of Wish.
I know if I'm asking it or like oh,
I don't wanna be not in the know.
So real quick, one more time, high,
how many people have heard
of Wish the shopping app?
Look around everyone just to get a sense.
Great, that's a lot actually now.
Put your hands down.
How many people have not ever heard of it?
Raise your hands high.
Appreciate it, thank you.
So Wish, depending on
who you believe is doing
between six conservatively
and $12 billion in revenue.
It's a shopping app, they
spend all their money
on Facebook ads, 95%.
The only things they've really done
that maybe you've seen is they have
the patch on the Lakers Jersey
and during the MacGregor Mayweather fight,
they had the logo in the corners
and in the middle of the ring.
12 billion, nine, six, at this point
somatically doesn't matter,
it's probably one of the only
potential long-term competitors of Amazon,
yet most people still don't know it exists
because the way they did marketing
was under-priced attention in Facebook.
The disproportionate.
I promise you if everybody
here knew how to do it,
there's a lot of nuances and
we'll get into some Q and A
but if everybody knew how to do it,
five mile radius of your branches,
using the data to find your prospects,
if everybody here really knew
how to be a modern-day
Facebook and LinkedIn marketer,
your business would be
dramatically different.
There is no radio or local television
or outdoor or direct mail campaign
that fires better than those two places
when you understand creatively what to do.
The flexibility of these
platforms to put content out
that resonates with the end consumer
'cause you're targeting
people of certain incomes
or certain genders or
things of that nature
is just too remarkable to
overcome for the other platforms
that require vanilla.
Your direct mail eight-by-twelve
is the same picture to everybody,
that same message you're
trying to get across
of why your branch is so
awesome just a mile away
needs 39 different pictures and videos
to 39 different segments psychographically
and demographically on Facebook.
That's why it converts.
If you make one video or
picture on a five mile radius,
it acts more like direct mail and radio.
This is about knowing.
Guys, ROI of having the skill.
The ROI of a basketball for LeBron James
is going to be over a billion dollars.
For me it's negative 3,000,
I've torn both of my meniscus.
To me, that's the punchline.
So what I'm passionate
about is getting this room
to understand that they
need to figure out something
that is practical to become
a modern-day marketer.
For example, let's talk
about underpriced attention.
These are platforms that I believe
if you spend money on are a better deal
than if you spent it somewhere else,
then the words of the videos
become the variable if it's successful.
Number one, podcasts.
How many people here are
actively listening to podcast?
Raise your hand.
Actually, you know what, do
me a favor that's important.
If you listen to a podcast,
and it could be many
different one or the same one,
if you listen to a
podcast most of the week,
like two or three times
a week or more stand-up.
Just do me a favor, let's
get the blood flow going.
Stand up if you are actively
listening to podcasts.
We're talking about 60 (mumbles)
maybe that's a little weak.
All right, thank you, you can sit down.
For me one of the most interesting places
to market right now is podcast.
If you're a bigger brand in the room
'cause obviously some aren't,
but if you're a bigger brand
buying pre-roll I've read
podcasts right now on shows
that you think hit your demographic
or potentially as narrow
as financial shows as broad
as something that might be
considered high net worth
if you're looking for that
world, whatever it may be,
you've got to make those decisions.
But I will tell you this,
there's a great misunderstanding right now
of the worth of pre-roll podcasts
because the data isn't clear yet
of how many people are
listening or watching,
Apple is not really reporting yet.
In that youth, in that blurriness,
what I always deploy is common sense.
I know people are listening
to podcasts at scale,
I know that the companies that
have been actively marketing
on podcasts the last two years, MailChimp,
things of that nature are growing on it,
on the Seth Rogen Show,
they're growing dramatically.
One of the things that as you
can imagine as a street kid
from an immigrant family,
one of the great devastating
things that has happened
in our society and this is
based on 70 years of prosperity,
we have eliminated common
sense from our businesses.
Do you know me people here live their life
as a human one way but
then as soon as they go
into the office say
completely different things
about their marketing?
Who here can't wait to
leave Vegas, run home
and carefully go through
their direct mail?
(audience laughing)
Guys, I mainly work with
fortune 500s, the Budweiser,
actually, how many people here happen
to see the Dwyane Wade Budweiser video
that made everybody cry?
Raise your hands.
So I appreciate that.
So that's a bigger media execution
that we're super proud of.
What I'm Way more proud of is
more than any Super Bowl ad
or anything else they've
done on television
the sales of Budweiser in
Miami and ironically Chicago
where he's from and he
played for a few minutes
have exploded, right.
I mean a lot of people saw
it, the costs were much less.
And here's where it gets crazy,
we didn't even have to spend on Facebook
and YouTube that heavily because
when you make great
content it travels itself.
There is no commercial on
television or newspaper ad
or cold call that goes viral.
There's no taking that and passing it on.
As all of you know word-of-mouth
is the foundational thing
to business and that is the great thing...
Social media in our society today
and it's something I've been
talking about for a decade,
I am not naive or unaware
of where everybody
wants to position it.
It's because Americans don't like
to be held accountable for anything.
So when the banking crisis happens,
it was your guy's fault, right,
not me even though I
was a $100,000 in debt
making $87,000 a year and
thought it was a good idea
to buy a $537,000 home.
In a decade, we're gonna
blame colleges for collapsing
'cause all the college debt,
but it's not gonna be our fault
for not being self-aware and understanding
that $80,000 in debt for a piece of paper
that doesn't get you a job is a bad deal.
So that is what I spend a lot of time,
our inability to be held accountable.
And so I just think it's
a very interesting time
in marketing, I highly
recommend looking at podcast.
Number two, LinkedIn.
LinkedIn is gonna feel
natural for this crowd
'cause it feels more mature,
older, you know, great.
I'm thrilled, if you follow
my content for last 10 years,
especially my last book, I
didn't even have a LinkedIn,
I had a chapter on every platform.
I didn't put LinkedIn in it
'cause it was so irrelevant.
Only 24 months ago, for a
niche group of B2B businesses,
there was a way to go.
Over the last 24 months, it is transformed
into a content platform for
all shapes and sizes business.
I've pushed fitness experts
to go put out LinkedIn content
of like three tips when you travel,
it's become literally
Facebook seven eight years ago
where the organic reach of your content
can go much further than you can imagine.
I genuinely believe that
every bank, credit union
and financial advisor
if they're building up
a personal brand in here needs to have
a very significant LinkedIn strategy
but the content that comes
out has to bring value.
You need to think of
yourself as Bloomberg,
you need to think of yourself
as the New York Times,
you need to think of yourself as Fox News,
you need to think of yourself as content,
not as a salesperson.
You need to put out content
that builds awareness
and brings value to somebody in ideas
that you should be thinking
about when buying a home.
Six ways to hack a business loan,
things that actually
bring value to people.
You can do that now, as
you think about your team
and your agency partners, you
have to become very self-aware
you need to think about
a couple of things.
Number one, you absolutely have to think
about how do you communicate best?
I do it through video and
then I strip the video
and make audio and that's
how I do my podcast,
but I'm not a great writer.
So I get interviewed by my writer
and then it becomes first person.
Not everybody has to do everything best
but you do have to be self aware
of how you communicate
to your end consumer.
The written word, voice
and video have always been
and will always be the three platforms.
You have to decide how your organization
is going to do that best.
The other thing is you
have to audit the people
that are executing this.
How many people here work
with outside agency partners?
Raise your hands.
Great, this is a big
one, this is a big one.
Now that I've been in the
industry for the last 10 years,
one of the things that has
been very obvious to me
is that most agencies are incentivized
to make their own margin which means
by nature being a client service provider
has a disconnect of misaligned interest.
A lot of the advice you're getting
and the reports that justify it right now
are completely predicated
on that agency's margins.
The reason that television
and programmatic digital
continued to be the beacons
for the biggest companies
in the world is because
that's where all the margin is
for the biggest media
agencies in the world.
And even for small shops,
they will always reverse
engineer to their biggest margin.
Because I built VaynerMedia for myself
because my long-term plan, I
didn't mention this earlier,
with my agency was not only
to learn but it was also
to take advantage of the
next economic downturn
because I believe everybody's
so grossly over leveraged
because we didn't properly
pay the piper in 2009
that I believe that there's gonna be
some significantly
great deals to be bought
when the world melts.
And earlier that whole rich thing...
How many people here are
immigrants or kids of immigrants?
Raise your hands.
So for the small hands that went up,
immigrants have figured out
a really interesting trick,
it's called Sit on Cash.
And it's funny, my
financial advisors and I
have a lot of friction because
I do very high risk investing
and then I send them way too
much cash for their liking
but my point is I'm gonna
make that cash work for me,
I'm patient, I'm gonna wait for
the next economy to collapse
and when that happens all
of a sudden $4 million
acts like 16, $16 million acts like 160.
There is no compounding
value on the market
or anything else that
makes it work that way
if that's what I wanna do with my money.
So I think that there's a
really interesting thing
of why my agency's been
able to figure it out
is 'cause I'm building it for myself
to buy things and run it through.
This is how I figured
out, why was everybody
giving such bad advice.
Guys, if your company is
buying a banner ad on a website
that is mainly seen on a
desktop, not on a phone,
below the fold, you
can't waste money faster.
There's not a...
Please if you do any...
As a matter of fact, leave now.
Leave the conference, leave my talk,
go back to the office and stop any cent
spent on banner ads on
websites, it is a literal joke.
As much as I hate television commercials
'cause watch this, watch this.
Not 16 year old crowd, you ready?
Watch this, by show of hands,
how many people here now
mainly watch when they watch
television Netflix, Hulu,
Amazon or HBO or when
it's on video on demand
and you fast-forward commercials?
Raise your hands,
Netflix, raise them high.
Keep them up, I want
everybody in the front
in these fancy couches to look back.
Look at this.
(audience laughing)
Keep them up for a second.
Can we all agree that
the majority of people
in this audience aren't
14 year old teenage girls.
This audience almost 95% of you
don't even have a chance
of seeing a commercial.
Forget about if you consumed it
and got inspired to do business,
95% of this older crowd
is not even got a prayer
of seeing an actual television
commercial $60 billion spent
to make you buy things in America
on television commercials.
Then you've got digital
banner ads, nobody...
Who here does click the banner ad?
(audience laughing)
Can somebody raise your...
The only banner ads you click
are once I went to your website,
you got me in the funnel,
you re-targeted me and then you annoyed
the living shit out of
me to buy those socks
or take that mortgage
and then I clicked it.
It is not a consideration funnel,
it is a retention and retargeting funnel.
We are broken in marketing in 2019.
The reason the Toys R Us is
in the sears of the world
and you'll see it every
single day in every market,
it's coming guys, it's coming.
And honestly it's actually here.
And you know what I'm most worried about?
How much damn margin and how profitable
the companies in this room actually are.
The biggest thing that I struggled
to push a new agenda in marketing
is the current results of businesses.
When I spoke the Toys
R Us eight years ago,
they were thrilled with their business.
They didn't wanna hear it.
This is what happens every time.
The only audience I'm worried about
when I go pitch a new client or speak here
is one that is currently
successful, that's what happens.
Things are always good before they're bad.
And so I just don't
understand the following.
If you believe 50% of what I'm saying,
the reason I started a marketing company
not a build a technology company
is because it's the easiest
thing to change, it just is.
You can go home and change it, you can.
And I think the days of like, I mean...
I literally have clients
that are spending more money
on outdoor billboards than they are
in Facebook and Instagram.
I don't know if you guys, when
you leave this conference,
can you please just look at everybody
who's driving on the highway.
Let me promise you this,
every single person
that's a passenger is
looking at their phone.
So I think we can all
agree in 2019 versus 1999,
billboards should not
have gone up in price.
At least half the audience
has been eliminated from seeing it.
The scarier part when you
look at people driving,
if you happen to do
this which is what I do,
is half the people driving
are looking at their phone.
(audience laughing)
You guys are scary out there.
We are not deploying common-sense behavior
against what's actually
happening with our consumers
and that is why we were
becoming long-term vulnerable.
Now let's go into you're
buying in, fine Gary,
I'll call your bluff.
Let's talk about YouTube real quick.
One of the greatest ad
products in the world today
is a specific product that
YouTube has which allows you
to target people who
searched on Google something
and then go to youtube
to watch something completely different.
They searched for a
mortgage or a loan or a bank
or whatever on Google and
then three days later,
they go to watch a UFC clip on YouTube,
they go watch a ski clip.
But the pre-roll is you,
before they watch that,
they literally type in,
looking to borrow some money
and literally your pre-roll
before their ski video is,
hey, are you looking to borrow some money?
And they're like, holy
shit, how'd you know?
(audience laughing)
It's an incredible product,
I highly recommend you look at it.
The key though is it's very
hard to make a compelling video
that gets somebody excited.
This is one big game.
Once you get into the framework
of understanding how underpriced
the digital landscapes,
certain digital landscape products are,
the game that you're gonna
get caught in to is content.
A lot of people are here
spending a lot of time
thinking about their media agency
but they're not spending time thinking
about the content they put in there.
The most important word in
today's digital centric world
of marketing is context.
This is one big game of
having enough content
to match the 30 to 80
different psychographic
and demographic cohorts
that are potentially
doing business with you.
This is a very big deal.
What we have not committed to
in our industry of marketing
is spending enough money
or spending money properly
to make enough pieces of content.
It is remarkable for me to watch
early-stage startup companies
out market much bigger companies
because they don't know any better
because they're just
living in an Instagram,
Facebook, YouTube world.
You will be blown away what happens
when you put a Asian-American
in the picture or video
and then target Asian-Americans
with the same message
and then run a separate ad
with an African-American female in it
and you run it against
African-American females
in a five-mile radius then
an African-American male,
18 to 21, gets a different
message than 58 to 63,
then income levels.
There is a graph, a framework of 40 to 70
significant segmentations in our society.
And then not to mention the subtle nuances
of your neighborhood.
I'll give you a weird one,
if you mark it in a certain
part of Illinois and Wisconsin,
like if you use Packer lingo
vs. Bear lingo or vice versa,
the conversions on your
sales are ludicrous
and through the roof.
If you're a national brand...
Look, I think we all know
what the political climate,
there are clearly two very
different points of view
on the current state of America,
your marketing needs to reflect that.
People value different things,
we understand that in our social issues
but as marketers we're trying
to sell vanilla to everybody.
This is one big game of content
that's contextual to the platform.
LinkedIn organic content,
you need to start
an editorial like capability
in your organization.
Facebook, you could hate it,
you could think Zack is the worst,
you could think the Russians,
you can think anything you want
but when you're in business,
you start realizing a lot of things.
Here's my favorite thing.
Everybody's out there
saying, screw you Facebook
and they're posting that on Instagram.
(audience laughing)
Headline readers versus practitioners.
People like to play hero on social media
but then don't back up their actions.
Their actions are very clear.
Right this second, Facebook
is the single best place
to market in the world because people
are still not pouring
enough money on the platform
because they're making emotional decisions
versus practical business decisions.
I could care less about Facebook,
I have way more Snapchat
and Pinterest stack,
things that I don't
believe are doing as well.
I wanna be historically correct
and I will stand up here
in 10 years and say,
you're still running ads
on Facebook and Instagram?
They're overpriced.
What's great about Google
and Facebook and Instagram
and Snapchat for that
matter and Pinterest,
is it's a marketplace.
Ads start at a penny, and
then supply and demand
for that attention goes up.
What's terrible about print
and radio and direct mail
is there dying mediums, they're not dead,
they're not doing as well as they used to
and you're paying the premium.
They keep raising prices,
that's a macro number
you might be locally doing
but that's fine, I don't know,
this is interesting to me
as business operator spending money.
We have such a passion for the past
that we're willing to
overpay for something
we know doesn't work in lieu of something
that's staring us in the face.
and then we make fun
of Venmo or Robin Hood,
Rock and More, AZebra.
We make fun of these
things, we say these things
and they're marketing a
completely different way
and they're growing by the second.
You're making fun of them
because you're not on their team.
The second you quit this
job and go work for them,
you're gonna sing its praises,
you have vested interest.
It's like how I talked about
the Patriots, I hate them.
They're cheaters, they're the worst,
I hate everything, I hope
they all die them, fuck them.
(audience laughing)
I'm a Jets fan, that's how I roll.
But that's sports,
that's me talking sports,
that's not real life.
You're doing that in real life,
you're making real life decisions
based on not being on a certain team.
Guys, this has happened.
You're not gonna get a
$100 million infusion
into your tech stack, rebuild
your app and your website
to create less friction
tomorrow but what you can do
is take a real step back and really start
auditing every penny that you spent.
There's no reason to waste money
because what I'm most
worried about is voice.
I will tell you it right now,
I'm putting this on the record.
Caleb, where are you?
Caleb, I film all my content,
I like being historically correct.
How many people here
follow me on Instagram?
A couple, thank you.
You can see in the last six months
I've been doing the recall videos.
Stuff I said in 11 that became true,
this is my currency over everything,
so I love speaking for me,
could care less about me,
the crowd, one thing, the truth.
The current state of the truth.
I don't sit up here and predict,
everything you've heard in my mouth,
it's things I've already seen happen.
This is not guessing,
this is not futurist,
this is not hoping.
This is everyday being a practitioner
spending a billion dollars in ad money
between my own agency and the
startups I'm involved with
and my own companies and
watching how it all plays.
By the way, one of the weird things
to throw you for a loop,
I think the Superbowl
is the number one thing everybody here
should run in marketing.
I think the Superbowl
is the most underpriced move in marketing.
Everybody in America will
know what you're up to
whether they watch it on
YouTube or during the game.
Another weird one, I'm starting
to really pay attention
to the collapsing prices
of Drive Time Radio, right.
Everybody's listening to
podcasts and Spotify, I get that.
To me it's not growing, I
just care if it's a good deal.
By the way I'll buy a million
television commercials
next year if they drop
their prices by 85%.
So for me I just really I'm desperate
for everybody to
understand how real this is
because I've now lived more
than two decades of business,
have yelled about this is gonna happen,
this is gonna happen!
People don't take it seriously
or not incentivized to
or to care less or...
And it's tougher for employees.
Back to when I used to
do it with entrepreneurs,
it was their family
business, that made sense.
It's hard for you to fight a machine
that you don't even own, I get it.
But I will say this, and this is probably
the single best thing I
can say in a room like this
for the future of your career;
The number one thing I am passionate about
is for everybody in this
room to consider the value
and the ROI of (mumbles),
for dying on your own sword.
That was amazing that it went out, right,
when I was about...
(audience laughing)
That was so amazing.
If you guys were doing that in the back,
that was unbelievable,
big shout out to them.
The number one thing that
I wish for all of you
is when you're sitting in a
meeting with senior executives
or your marketing team or your agencies
and you're talking about marketing,
if you have an opinion
that you believe in,
not because I said it, because
you actually went home,
you know, if you're...
How many people here are senior
marketers in their company?
Raise your hands.
For all of you that just raised your hand,
if you don't go home and
spend 200 bucks on Facebook
to try to sell something
that's sitting in your basement
on Facebook marketplace,
it would be a huge mistake.
You can't have opinions about
something you don't know.
You must be a practitioner, please.
So let me get to the point.
If you're in a meeting tomorrow, next week
and we're talking about
Facebook or Instagram
or radio or television or
print and you have an opinion
that's different than what
you as the professional
is going along with, the ROI
of you voicing that opinion
is that everybody else knows you said it.
And it might not be valuable today
but when everything hits
the fan, and it will,
in three or four years, the people
that were historically correct
will get the first jobs.
That's real life.
I've watched for too
long over the last decade
friends of mine pander to the
companies that they worked in
on things they didn't believe
only then to feel the wrath
when the company got hurt and
they didn't have the resume
of articulating their
truth to protect them
and so they lost twice.
If nothing else, if
nothing else this morning,
please in meetings talk about
what you actually believe in
instead of what's convenient
for the short term
because the haves and
have-nots of marketing
are becoming very clear.
The stakes are very high.
Let me bounce here for
a couple more minutes
while I've got it.
One thing to really understand
and why so many people are
struggling with marketing today
is this is the greatest
era of math and art
being equal partners.
Way too many marketers today
either run too much quant
or they run too much art.
This world too much quant,
math math math, right,
way too much, not building brand
which is why voice is gonna be a problem.
Voice is gonna be a problem
because everything we now do
on our mobile phone over
the next decade or two,
an enormous percentage of that activity
is going to go to voice
devices because it's faster.
The only thing we value is speed.
We give up...
There is no privacy concerns in America,
we prove it every day, we don't care.
We care about convenience, we like time,
we like lack of friction.
It is faster for me to say, hey Alexa,
I'll take two burgers and a fries
than it is to find my phone
go to Seamless and order it.
Many more transactions.
I grew up as a kid that was told nobody
would buy wine on the internet,
that nobody would buy
tomatoes on the internet,
a car on the internet.
We buy all things on the internet.
The Internet is real
life, this is fake life.
And so please understand the
reason I'm pushing brand,
the reason the Dwyane Wade thing mattered
is 'cause building brand is
going to be the difference
between somebody saying
Alexa, send me a case of beer
and Alexa send me Budweiser.
That is going to be everything
in the next frontier
and if you're a young executive...
How many people here are retiring
within the next 10 years?
And I don't mean that
you're gonna crush it
and go buy a plane,
(audience laughing)
I mean you're old and
you're kind of finished.
(audience laughing)
Great, great, okay.
So for 9% of this
audience, I will say this;
Nothing I'm saying is
futurist, it all matters now,
but obviously as you can imagine
for the other 91%
percent of this audience,
a decade from now, let me remind you
that almost nothing we
talk about today existed
a decade and a half ago, nothing, nothing.
This is gonna compoundly grow,
it's gonna get way crazier and scarier
if you don't like this stuff
and I desperately need you
to understand that the,
and this is actions over words,
in a world where I could
have gone the VC route
and had a lot of easy life and lived it,
I wanted to build a marketing machine
to take advantage of how big this is
because I believe that
everything in our society
is predicated on communicating,
it's why dictators take over the press
when they first have a coup.
Communication matters, and we are living
through the transition of communication.
We have gone from a radio first world
to a television first world,
we now actively live in a
mobile device world first.
That's just where we are.
And when you look at the mobile phone,
the far majority of
activity besides gaming
and entertainment is on social networks.
If your business does not
know how to communicate
on those seven to 10 platforms,
every day your relevance
of brand is declining.
This is very important.
This is not ha ha ha fun,
this is massively disruptive.
And the naivete that I've
seen from governments
and politicians and other big
companies in different sectors
is happening here right
now in this industry,
I have a first view at it.
It's why I love working
with Chase so much.
Kristen Lemcke was one
of the most progressive
thoughtful CMOS period that I work with,
let alone in this sector,
pushing the envelope
around relevance of brand
whether it's Sarena and Curry
for that kind of cultural stuff,
whether it's the tactics of eliminating,
all those banner ads that we used to buy.
She's on it, sharp as a tack.
And she's in an ivory tower
at the biggest companies in the world.
Many people here are in the trenches
should know can absolutely do this.
I think you need to have a call in arms,
this has to be the morning,
we have to scrutinize
the money we're spending,
we have to scrutinize the reports
that we are held accountable
that everybody here knows
don't actually match to
the reality of our business
and we have to put pressure
on the most senior executives
that sit on boards and C-suites
that pontificate about
the past or asking for ROI
within a minute of the spend
because all those behaviors
that I just mentioned
are the singular reason
that great companies
that make tons of profit
wake up seven years later
and are no longer in business.
Please, please heed this,
it's coming 'cause it's
already here, thank you.
(audience applauding)
(bright upbeat music)